families call it the knock
and it's life-changing wood actually
slept in which is a rare thing for me
and the kids we're always up early and
we were walking by a knock then knock at
the door
it was two detectives who were looking
for me ex-partner obviously it was very
out of the ordinary
I'd never dealt with the police before
neither had he so I just had to take the
kids to school and go to work not
knowing what was going on
this is the way most families learn
their partner or parent is suspected of
online child sex offenses
it was the way the nightmare started for
Jessica and her three children who were
all under 12.
her words have been spoken by an actor
you feel
I felt
dirty
that was how it made me feel
that I've been with somebody who has
done those things
and for your children and for my
children the same again especially my
daughter because that was
how to even begin to comprehend
that was somebody who was an amazing dad
and somebody you look up to has done
something like that
The Shame of the crime brought the
stigma of Association Jessica and her
children moved home and schools
experiencing a trauma more families are
facing than ever before
new data shared with Sky News shows that
every month in England and Wales there
are more than 800 arrests in connection
with online child sex abuse and
researchers say that 35 of those people
that's about 300 a month have children
living with them at the time of their
arrest
and their experiences can be harrowing
these children's accounts shared with
Sky News have been spoken by actors
I got a text that some boys from school
had added me into a WhatsApp group
but my dad
one message said if our dad had done
what your dad had done we'd kill
ourselves
we had to move away
or had to move schools we had to change
our names
and when I went to see Daddy in prison
I wasn't allowed to sit on his knee
I am not allowed to say his name in
school because I will get attacked by my
friends everyone says I can't love him
but
Can't Stop
their stories are hard to hear but these
children aren't defined as victims they
aren't legally entitled to things like
free counseling in fact they get fewer
automatic Services than the offender
like Jessica's ex-partner
finding out that he got Psychotherapy
paid for for quite some time
and me and my children were you know at
home suffering whilst he's done what
he'd done and you know I was having to
go out and
sorry
work really long hours and even more so
to be able to just afford just to be
heard
and under current laws this isn't
changing so I'm going to read to you
from the government's victims code and
this is important because this defines
who is a victim in the eyes of local
authorities and who gets things like
automatic support free counseling for
example and it says a victim is a person
who has suffered harm including physical
mental or emotional harm or economic
loss which was directly caused by a
criminal offense to currently children
of offenders aren't covered by this
definition and when we contacted the
ministry of Justice about this they said
they do have a great deal of sympathy
for families of offenders but it's
Charities that right now provide a wide
range of freely available Services
basic and listening support to more
intensive one-to-one work but the
Charities themselves say there are
children being missed knee Pac supports
children of offenders but even they
admit they don't know how many may need
help there's no database there's no
information anywhere so
we estimate how many children are
affected by imprisonment
um per year but we don't have that
accurate figure which is quite
concerning why don't we have that figure
though there's just no statutory body
that has any
responsibility for for creating that
data we know there are gaps in Services
where we do need to be offering more
support but we don't have them
statistics and there will be families
and children that we are missing that
we're not reaching out to and what does
their future then look like research
shows 65 percent of boys with fathers in
prison end up in the criminal justice
system themselves in an exclusive
interview with Sky News the British
police lead on Child Protection says
families of sex offenders are hidden
victims and they could be legally
defined as such that's under a
discussion that's a clearly a matter
that comes under statute under the
victims victims code as well I think
anybody listening to this anybody who
has been subject to this any partner or
child would would rightly
um clearly recognize the need to provide
the most care because if we don't get
this right that adverse impacts on
children can have a huge impact for the
rest of their lives and that is so sad
you know almost the removal of a parent
out of their house in such a dramatic
and impactive way clearly requires uh
Mental Health Services for for children
and then we will also very much focus on
the children and the partners Left
Behind as you describe who are the
hidden victims of this
[Music]
the government says there are no plans
to adapt the victim's code to
incorporate families like Jessica's who
feel invisible
vulnerable and very alone
Katrina Vuitton Sky News